- [Instructor] Life on Earth has existed
for billions of years.
Humans know this, not because we've been
around the whole time, but instead,
thanks to the discovery of fossils,
which tell us about organisms
that lived in the distant past.
Scientists have found millions of fossils.
Some, such as skeletons,
document ancient organisms'
anatomy or physical features,
while others, such as
preserved footprints,
record organisms' behaviors.
Each fossil that has been found
is like a piece of a giant puzzle.
To see the bigger picture of
the history of life on Earth,
scientists have to study the many fossils
and see how they all fit
together in the larger puzzle.
All of the fossil puzzle pieces
that have been discovered,
along with their relative ages,
make up Earth's fossil record.
The fossil record is basically
a history of life on Earth
as documented through fossils.
By studying the fossil record,
scientists can see how life on Earth
has changed over evolutionary time.
The fossil record allows
us to see patterns
of evolutionary changes that have happened
throughout Earth's history.
These include an overall increase
in organism complexity and diversity
and the changes that have occurred
along evolutionary lineages,
showing us how one group of organisms
could have evolved to the next.
The fossil record also shows us
when certain groups of
organisms went extinct.
First, let's take a look at the increase
in organism complexity and diversity
that is seen in fossil record.
Over evolutionary time,
organisms have generally
become more complicated.
Some of the oldest known fossils
are formations made by ancient
colonies of cyanobacteria.
These fossils provide evidence
that single-celled organisms
were living on Earth
roughly around 3.5 billion years ago
and that these organisms
were relatively simple,
similar to the bacteria we have today.
The fossil record then goes
on to document major leaps
in complexity of life on
Earth, with, for example,
the large tube-shape
cells of Grypania spiralis
and the macroscopic organisms
in the Francevillian biota.
According to scientists, these fossils,
which are dated to be roughly
from 2 billion years ago,
could provide evidence of some
of the earliest eukaryotic,
or nucleus-containing cells,
and of the earliest
multicellular organisms.
Not only does the fossil record show
an increase in complexity
over evolutionary time,
but also an increase in the
diversity of life on Earth.
For example, the Cambrian Explosion
describes a multimillion
year span of time,
beginning about 539 million years ago,
in which there was a huge increase
in the diversity of animals on Earth.
Almost all of the animal
lineages we know today
actually got started during this period.
All of these increases in
complexity and diversity
have given rise to the
millions of varied organisms
that live on Earth today.
Next, let's take a look at the changes
that can be seen along
the evolutionary lineages
in the Earth's fossil record.
But before we do that,
let's quickly look back at
how scientists study fossils.
As you may recall, fossils are
found in sedimentary rocks,
meaning that the deeper the fossil,
the older the fossil is likely to be.
So based on the layers in
which the fossil is found,
scientists can put them in order by age.
And in doing this,
scientists can piece together
the evolutionary steps of
how one type of organism
could have evolved into the next,
eventually giving rise
to the living organisms
we see today.
To give an example of this,
did you know that birds are
actually direct descendants
of a group of dinosaurs called theropods?
It may be hard to believe,
but the fossil record shows
that an organism known as Archaeopteryx
existed about 150 million years ago,
towards the end of the Dinosaur Age,
but before the appearance of modern birds.
This organism in
particular is interesting,
because it had some features
unique to theropod dinosaurs,
such as jaws and sharp teeth
and some features unique
to birds, such as feathers.
So Archaeopteryx represents
an evolutionary transition
between theropod dinosaurs and
birds in the fossil record.
Finally, let's take a look
at the patterns of extinction
seen in the fossil record
with the help of our extinct
friend, the Triceratops.
Extinction happens when a
species completely dies out.
In the fossil record, extinctions show up
as organisms of a certain species
being present in older rock layers
and then completely disappearing
from the newer rock layers.
For example, we only
see Triceratops fossils
in rock layers that are roughly
68 to 66 million years old.
After this, we don't find any evidence
of Triceratops fossils anywhere
and there certainly aren't
any Triceratops living today.
The Triceratops is an important
example of extinction,
as they not only went extinct,
but they went extinct due
to a mass extinction event.
Mass extinction events happened
when large-scale environmental change
caused many groups of
organisms to go extinct
around the same time.
When we see the triceratops disappear
from the fossil record,
we also see other types of
organisms disappear, too,
providing evidence for
the mass extinction event
that led to the disappearance
of all non-avian dinosaurs.
And with that, you now know
what Earth's fossil record is
and the various patterns it can show us.
Earth's fossil record is an essential tool
that scientists use to piece together
the history of life on Earth.
And new fossils are
continuously being discovered,
so the fossil record is more
than just a collection of fossils.
It's a window into the
mysteries of the past
and it's ever-growing
record of how life on Earth
came to be what it is today.